you're a child awake at night what a
feeling in your room you cling to these
rare hours of the evening and watch the
hour hand crawl closer towards the parts
of the clock you've never seen touched
now you stare out your window embracing
the moon the stars and the darkness that
engulfs them you trace an owl's hoo-hoos
up towards the densest evergreen in the
neighborhood you see a rat scurry across
the top of a brick wall you wave to your
new nocturnal friends bonded by the
preference of night now you open your
window and inhale smelling the dark sky
like chocolate cake you hold it in as
long as you can very soon you know it
will all be taken from you not by a god
or a black hole or any of the universe's
hypothesized collapses at this age you
know nothing of physical cosmology you
know nothing of the book of revelation
you're just a child the forces that give
and take from you are not understood
through physics nor philosophy nor
through numbers nor thought experiments
look at you your thumb is still pruned
from having just kicked the habit of
sucking it your pajamas are still one
unified piece of clothing cradling your
entirety with fuzzy con your teddy bear
is still an extension of your arm not
yet removed by maturity you're still
another 15 years from believing your
life is dictated by astrological signs
or personal free will or mathematical
outputs it's not that you're ignorant in
fact you're quite bright as a child you
don't bother to comprehend the forces
outside your house because you know as
long as you are living inside it they
have no governance the only true comes
from within from the two gods you have
seen with your very own eyes sitting on
the ripped sofa in gray sweatpants
watching a show about rich people
drinking mimosas on boats in the
mediterranean the almighty parents
rulers of everything
and with just one compound word called
up the stairs they have the power to
take everything away from you bedtime
and suddenly the curtains are pulled
over the world you longed for now it's
not the stars but the ceiling you're
staring at but thankfully you are not
alone you pull your teddy bear out from
its hibernation beneath your armpit and
you hug him gently careful not to
squeeze out his stuffing laying there
you can't help but wonder how your bear
got like this so beaten and bruised torn
up like a dog toy one eye dangling from
a string his left leg bends forward
impersonating the joint structures of a
flamingo yet as far as you know your
best pal has done nothing but sleep how
is he so battered can hibernation be
that taxing do teddy bears expire the
questions for now must be ignored you
lay there together in your bed fighting
the feelings of slumber almost as if
rebelling against mom and dad's tyranny
thinking deeply only makes you sleepier
and tonight you insist on staying awake
it's 9 30 and you've yet to be sucked
into a dream and that in itself is a
small victory but your parents wishes
will not be evaded that easily if ever
they fight back by turning on the air
conditioning the soft rhythmic humming
of the white noise weighs on your eyes
and soon you can't resist it any longer
sleep sneaks up on you the battle is
lost a safe 10 minutes later your
parents poke their heads into your room
and see your body stiff and motionless
wrapped in sheets like a mummy they
celebrate their victory with a quick
kiss and go back to the sofa to rest
like gods on the seventh day and while
you are sleeping dreaming of a tomorrow
where you don't surrender to the same
powers there is yet another battle to be
fought and if all goes well you'll sleep
right through it but some children won't
be so lucky on july 7 2001 a portland
oregon news headline reported a young
boy missing from home in the middle of
the night his parents were quick to
respond that their son wasn't the type
of boy to go wandering out into the dark
and that something suspicious was sure
to be discovered there in his bedroom
the first thing noticed was his stuffed
animal a jovial orca torn to shreds its
stuffing scattered across the carpet its
head and body were stationed in the
corner nearest the bed soaked in a black
substance similar to ink its eyes damp
with water the boy however was not to be
found as the parents held their son's
dismantled orca in their hands feeling
the weight of mortality they comb their
fingers through the stuffed animal's
organs as if giving it an impromptu
autopsy trying to determine what kind of
beast could have done this but it wasn't
justice for the orca they were after by
the time we are old enough to be parents
we've outgrown empathy for our inanimate
counterparts for them the orca was
simply a representation of the cruel
fate that may have also been bestowed on
their child its death was only respected
for how it related to the living and so
the poor orca was set aside forgotten
about until investigators called upon
the foundation to intervene at which
point mtf iota 12 were dispatched it
revealed that the young boy's room had
large trails of viscous black liquid
streaking the walls the very same liquid
found on the orca but where did this
liquid come from unfortunately there was
no camera footage to give us the answer
neither were there eyewitness reports or
any residual signs of what specifically
occurred neighbors who were awake
reported hearing the thump thump
thumping from the room which as expected
was useless by standard insight leading
to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations maybe it was an
extremely localized earthquake maybe he
was just throwing a temper tantrum but
where does maybe this maybe that lead us
to can factual answers ever come from
this level of uncertainty well one
specific maybe just may be the key to
cracking this case allow me to explain
two days after the event the child was
rediscovered unconscious behind a hedge
in the family's garden a brief interview
revealed that the child witnessed the
final minutes of what he described as an
intense battle he claimed my orca was
fighting a big monster and then the
monster grabbed me and took me out the
window but someone saw it so it dropped
me and i hid in the bush a second
interview revealed no other discoveries
but the child claimed that the monster
ate his socks initial reactions to the
two interviews were as expected adults
reasoned the claims were imaginary a
fabrication of the child's mind
manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured
actually was but heard beneath the
skeptical murmurs of jaded grown-ups
enslaved by their narrow perceptions was
one individual who dared to suggest
maybe just maybe the boy is telling the
truth and it was in the spirit of this
hopeful and trusting maybe that the
foundation would prove the boy's story
to be truth and the truth would be known
as scp-6330
scp-6330 is a phenomenon affecting
stuffed animals worldwide though it is
most common in teddy bears manifestation
of this phenomenon is referred to as a
sleepwalker event occurring only within
the households of families with young
children typically between the ages of 1
to 14 while you're asleep vulnerable to
what lingers awake your favorite stuffed
animal may find life impulsively
combating enemies referred to as
scp-6330-2 these creatures typically
blend with shadows though this mechanism
is poorly understood they somewhat
resemble creatures associated with
fantasy such as dragons or ogres always
manifesting beneath your bed no matter
how messy or clean it might be
scp-6330-2 instances depict behavior
indicating that they intend to hurt or
prey upon the sleeping child and it
isn't night lights or security systems
that stop them but rather scp-6330-1
scp-62
are stuffed animals already present in a
child's room that seem to be
non-anomalous prior to
scp-6330-2 manifestations
scp-633-1 has been shown to
instantaneously manifest small wooden
weaponry in order to combat
scp-6330-2 to protect their child
battles have been shown to last upwards
of 20 minutes and are always near silent
there is an unspoken agreement between
both sides to keep their history
concealed as best as they can in
observed cases
scp-6330-1 have emerged victorious
though are severely wounded during the
skirmish torn wool and stuffing are
common and following all known events
scp-6330-1 have died due to their
injuries but only after sacrificing
themselves for the safety of the child
prior to death the instance will drag
the scp-6330-1
corpse back under the bed frame and
d-manifest to understand this the
foundation has conducted just one test
given the volatile nature of recreating
the events the foundation did not push
their luck with subsequent studies and
so it's the lone research done in 1987
on site 44 that they still lean on to
this day to understand scp-6330
and the instances that come with it it
began with a researcher volunteering his
seven-year-old daughter henceforth
referred to as subject to be placed in a
humanoid containment room and soothed to
sleep using a teddy bear that she had a
strong emotional attachment to for 12
straight tests our subject was observed
to sleep through the night peacefully
her environment remaining in alignment
with the trivialities of deep sleep but
on the 13th study something would happen
something very unsettling even for the
foundation standards mtf iota 12 were
stationed at the room's entrance for
swift intervention if needed and until
that 13th attempt they felt their focus
to be pointless approaching the third
hour however they felt a subtle and
unexplained value in their presence they
felt something coming on that feeling
while danger is looming that feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in
case and just as they made eye contact
with one another to acknowledge this
shared feeling within the group a quiet
rustling sound was heard beneath the bed
and sounds reminiscent of a large
animal's breathing became audible
suddenly a pair of large scaly clawed
hands grasped the rim of the bed frame a
creature resembling a western dragon
emerged but was it actually a dragon
were the sheets ready to be blasted to
flames if slain would the next regrow
and multiply by the hundreds these
thoughts race through mtf iota 12's head
one member instinctually ran for the
door to go protect the child but he was
held back and restrained reminded that
the success of the experiment was
dependent on letting the situation play
out naturally he was hard to console
patience at this moment did not feel
like a virtue it felt irresponsible a
creature standing approximately three
meters above the ground switching
between bipedal and quadrupedal motion
was stalking a sleeping child and they
were instructed to simply watch for five
minutes the
scp-6330-2 patrolled the room moving
silently and methodically unaware of the
surveillance cameras then
scp-6330-2 turned towards the subject
positioning itself at the foot of the
bed stretching its arms out towards the
subject it gaped its jaws wide exposing
rows of large pointed teeth and a dark
pink tongue it looked like a snake in a
field of mice as it prepared to lunge at
the subject mtf iota 12 was ready to
intervene but before they could the
stuffed bear stood up on the subject's
chest and drew a small sword and shield
from an unknown source almost magically
like switching weapons in an old zelda
video game it positioned its sword's
tipped downward and held its shield at
its side
scp-6330-1 hunched over slightly and
twirled its sword maintaining eye
contact with
scp-6330-2 the entire way through after
10 seconds the
scp-6330-2 threw its jaws at the subject
and
scp-6330-1 responds with a leap towards
the subject's attacker slicing
scp-6330-2's eye the
scp-6330-2 responds with a quiet grunt
and touches its wound which leaks a
viscous black liquid the
scp-6330-1 jumps towards scp-6330-2
and mid-battle uses fabric from the bed
sheets to quickly stitch the wound
attempting to minimize mess and proof of
its presence both instances went to
battle for nine minutes before the first
signs of damage to scp-6330-1
following the severing of one of
scp-6330-2's dorsal spikes it strikes
the
scp-6330-1 with a heavy slap which sends
scp-6330-1
across the room it stands back up
placing a hand on its stomach and looks
at its hand which is now covered in wool
and stuffing they charge at each other
once again but as the subject moves
slightly in her sleep both instances
stop and quickly agree on peace until
the subject settles when that happens
the instances resume fighting research
notes that while the battle is genuine
there is an element of guidance they do
not follow a script but it appears they
follow a code while both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the
other neither wants it broadcasted to
the public after 20 minutes of battle
both instances are heavily scarred and
injured after kicking itself off of the
scp-6330-2's nose scp-60
sprints from one side of the room
towards scp-6330-2
leaping into the air and landing a fatal
blow slicing the neck of the other
instance which falls lifeless to the
floor scp-60
is dragged by the scp-6330-1
back under the bed a short while later
the
scp-6330-1 emerges damage sustained
includes loss of one buttoned eye
exposed stuffing and torn wool it places
its sword and broken shield on a nearby
nightstand
scp-6330-1 then drags itself up the bed
sheets towards the subject who is
sleeping peacefully throughout the test
it rests beside the child lying
motionless it seems to glare directly at
the camera and a small digit protrudes
from its round hand giving a thumbs up
to the researchers its head flops onto
the child's cheek before it ceases to
move the father who risked his daughter
for research is pleased with the
discoveries regarding both anomalies but
it brings about a new set of questions
concerning children and their
relationship with the dark these very
thoughts you might even wonder yourself
maybe a kid's desire to stay up past
bedtime isn't so much about wanting to
watch cartoons with curse words or read
calvin and hobbes maybe it's not about a
desire to be awake at all but rather a
subconscious fear of being asleep maybe
our senses as children are heightened to
the anomalies that creep about maybe all
the fabled fears of children aren't
fairy tales after all and maybe mom and
dad checking under our bed is just
performance parenting because even if
something were there would they even be
able to see it or is everything beyond
an adult's understanding misattributed
to the imagination as we age does our
perception of how reality should look
alter the reality that is actually there
do we indeed see clear with our
expensive glasses from our high-rise
office space or did we see more
accurately in the glow of our action
figure nightlight spying through
stitches in our blankets looking past
crusty eye boogers at what moved in the
shadows it is hard to ever know for
every real encounter a child has with an
scp-6330
there might be hundreds of falsehoods
the ratio is truly impossible to
calculate but as long as teddy bears are
universal so too are there anomalous
enemies and so where does that fact
leave us how do we go forward should we
be afraid to put our children to sleep
afraid of the monsters under their bed i
don't think that's what our hero would
want sometimes we have to learn to trust
things even if we don't understand them
like gravity or multiplication we have
to trust that the relationship between
children and their stuffed animals are
in fact real we have to learn their
loyalty is reciprocated even if the
adult world has taught us otherwise and
if we ever need a reminder of these
lessons we can look to event 184 in
cambridge england where we have our
first recording of a sleepwalker event
outside of controlled testing and also
our first piece of evidence proving
scp-6330-1 to understand language and
how to use it to connect with humans in
ways beyond being cute and cuddly on
november 11 2008 a call was filed to
local authorities by a family who
claimed to have discovered footage of a
sleepwalker event within their son's
room mobile task force iota 12 lucid
dreamers were dispatched to investigate
immediately the footage was seized by
personnel and all members of the family
were administered class a amnestics the
child's bed swayed lightly as an
instance of
scp-6330-2 emerges the instance
resembles an unknown creature though it
is described as having a large muscular
frame the instance walks to the opposite
end of the room hunching over and
observing the child for exactly 10
minutes as the
scp-6330-2 begins to stand further
upright it extends a retractable set of
claws then the child's teddy bear
suddenly stands drawing a bow and quiver
scp-6330-2 assumes a quadrupedal stance
and snarls before lunging towards the
bed the
scp-6330-1 fires a single arrow towards
the scp-6330-2
striking the instance directly in its
canine-like snout as
scp-6330-2 responds with a loud huff
reminiscent of that of a bull or bovine
the instances battle for approximately
30 minutes the longest recorded
sleepwalker event to date both show
abilities and skill sets consistent with
other
scp-6330-1 and dash 2 instances
eventually
scp-6330-2 has
scp-6330-1 pinned to a nearby wall and
tries to strangle it the
scp-6330-2 then pulls one of
scp-6330-1's arrows from its arm
plunging it into the dash one's chest
then the dash 2 leans its head towards
the dash 1 and whispers into the
instance's right ear though audio
recordings cannot determine exactly what
was vocalized the
scp-630-1 lifts up its head staring
blankly into
scp-6330-2's eyes it reaches behind its
back pulling out a small entirely wooden
glock 19 handgun the bear points the
weapon into
scp-6330-2's forehead and fires the shot
is silent and the
scp-6330-2's body falls limp black
viscous fluid sprays onto the wall the
scp-6330-1 hauls
scp-6330-2's corpse towards the bed
noticeably limping it drags the body by
its large forearm and demanifests upon
reaching the underneath of the bed scp
6330-1 returns and briefly stares around
the room before turning to the child it
climbs up a desk and finds a piece of
paper and a pen it goes on to write the
following note hello timothy thank you
for always taking care of me it really
was fun i was able to repay the favor of
protecting you unfortunately i am hurt i
need to go i'm too weak to stay and i
just hope you'll remember me it's been
fun helping you i've enjoyed my time
under your care going into this i knew
it would happen the sleepwalker is
coming for you
i'm just happy i could do my job goodbye
my friend i hope i may see you soon now
go check out scp-999 and the most
wholesome scps and top 14 friendliest
scps for more anomalies that'll just
warm your heart